[Musica]
capitale umano
io mi occupo circa da una ventina d'anni
di pittura
egigantismi su parete con varie tecniche
Parliamo di una delle sette discipline
dell'arte che la pittura diciamo l'arte
per convenzione e la pittura poi ci ce
ne sono anche altro ovviamente
mi occupo di praticare questa disciplina
in contesti sensibili infatti oggi sto
arrivando dritto dalla casa
circondariale di Ettore Scalas auto in
provincia di Cagliari dove sto
sviluppando un progetto sociale che va
avanti a vari capitoli ed è arrivato a
il terzo prima è un progetto legato alla
fragilità
nel contesto appunto introspettivo
interno alla vita di tutti i giorni
della casa circondariale e poi
successivamente
un progetto parallelo sulla
genitorialità sostanzialmente il mio
ruolo
non è soltanto quello di un pittore di
un artista ma mi calo nella parte nel
ruolo di una sorta di mediatore che ha
appunto
il modo di parlare con i figli delle
persone
detenute e con le famiglie prenderle per
mano
fargli impugnare una bomboletta spray e
tutti assieme in un contesto appunto
sensibile realizzare un'opera
partecipata
qua alle mie spalle c'è un fotogramma
invece
di un episodio della mia vita privata e
lavorativa che si è sviluppato in Africa
a casa Tu Marini un villaggio
piccolissimo gestito da una associazione
non governativa che mi ha ospitato
diversi giorni nella realizzazione di
tre opere
simboliche che hanno appunto Il lo scopo
di indagare quello che è un concetto
legato alla speranza
appunto la cooperazione tra individui
soprattutto nella fascia generazionale
adolescenziale da quella adolescenziale
in giù
Parliamo di un contesto appunto delicato
molto vicino a quello delle case
famiglia dove i più piccoli hanno
esigenze primarie la salute la fame
quindi di potersi sfamare e
immediatamente L'arte in questo contesto
fa tantissimi passi indietro perché non
è un'esigenza primaria però può dare un
valore aggiunto e quindi la si cerca di
incastrare combinare e in sinergia dare
un servizio alla società anche
attraverso la pittura attraverso il
colore e quel piccolo valore aggiunto
che dovrei dare io in prima persona
mi è capitato nella mia carriera e mi
continua a capitare mi reputo fortemente
appunto fortunato per questo di girare
il mondo con questi progetti il mio
percorso è iniziato nelle strade a
scorrimento veloce nell'abusivismo nella
riappropriazione di spazi urbani
collettivi fatiscenti i cosiddetti non
luoghi
le cosiddette arterie principali della
società dove scorrono Dove scorre la
vita Dove Scorrono le macchine dove c'è
lo spostamento massivo delle masse per
tutte le ragioni Vitali che che ci
spingono a farlo e io in questa
Tavolozza per 10 15 anni Ho dipinto le
mie opere con delle parole chiave
nascono appunto come un vero e proprio
Trading autogeno proiettato però alla
collettività alla società intera
con una ricaduta sociale notevole con
persone che ho anche l'orgoglio di dirlo
mi ringraziano in privato
semplicemente perché Leggono una parola
che per loro ha un peso
lo ha per me che lo scrivo che lo
disegno su larga scala Però anche loro
hanno una reazione particolare qua di
nuovo le mie spalle c'è un fotogramma di
un'opera
cosiddetta di Ground Art che cambia il
punto di vista
del fruitore quindi non è sicuramente
quello convenzionale su parete si tratta
di un contesto pubblico dove le persone
soprattutto
nato in un contesto pandemico quindi
un'esigenza durante l'epoca il periodo
del distanziamento sociale e affiorata
la l'esigenza appunto sociale in tutto
il mondo del
ripopolare i contesti pubblici legati
allo sport
e da qua nasce la tendenza anche
stilistica artistica architettonica di
dare un valore aggiunto una dignità
questi luoghi e quindi si è partito dai
contesti sportivi come Cambiati da
basket Questo è uno dei tanti che ho
realizzato è un'opera legata alla
Rinascita
è stata anche questa partecipata
attraverso
di le persone che vivono e popolano
questo campetto giocandoci Facendoci
tornei e mi hanno aiutato come spesso
succede in prima persona
l'arte pittorica quindi diventa Non Solo
Estetica
ma diventa anche etica si sforza esce da
quella zona di comfort si sforza a
dialogare con la società cerca di un
contatto un contatto visivo attraverso
il colore attraverso il non verbale un
contatto diretto attraverso la
comunicazione attraverso le parole
chiave ancora con le mie spalle l'opera
risveglio una di quelle a cui sono
particolarmente legato
nasce e si evolve in due mesi e mezzo di
lavoro ad agosto del 2020 quindi piena
pandemia anche lì e ho avuto appunto il
grande privilegio di evolvere e
continuare senza fermarmi la mia
carriera artistica lavorativa
servendo la società in un'altra opera di
Grand Floor e Ground Art
stavolta non partecipata Ma dove il
punto di vista
è forzato e dal cielo oppure a scelta
anche dalle case popolari del quartiere
Santa Teresa Pirri che un quartiere che
nasce grigio nasce svantaggiato nasce
nel buio
però poi una piccola macchia blu di
colore inizia a costellare l'intero
quartiere a macchia d'olio
e diventa un progetto legato a una ONLUS
a cui io sono molto caro Per cui lavoro
da più di 15 anni e che diciamo mi fa da
luce da apripista da via da guida in
quello che anche il mio percorso
artistico io
ho assimilato
una tendenza lavorativa sociale un
approccio anche umano anche grazie a
esser nato e cresciuto all'interno di
una ONLUS e quindi ho avuto il piacere
l'onore la formazione di poter capire
che cosa significhi fare anche del
volontariato
quindi questa è un'opera che parla da sé
c'è una parola chiave che il risveglio
Ci sono le tenebre attorno c'è
l'allegoria appunto di questo cielo
plumbeo che viene interamente squarciato
dalla luce da un plenilunio ancora qua
c'è un'opera recentissima di quest'anno
portata a compimento poco meno di due
settimane fa a Treviglio nella zona
industriale che come sappiamo
tutte le zone industriali
industriali hanno come colore
principale il grigio invece è nata una
esigenza di tipo sociale e soprattutto
privato da parte del committente di
creare uno sfondamento prospettico
legato
a Uno scorcio naturalistico questo è
sempre stato uno dei tanti progetti che
ho curato attraverso le scuole sono
state
molte volte più di tre classi
tra superiori e medie e in maniera
Attiva hanno
partecipato quest'opera l'hanno resa
propria
aiutandomi e avendo una visione
dell'Opera stessa differente da quel
quella distanza che tutti abbiamo Quando
veniamo un opera d'arte qualunque dentro
un museo fuori dal museo murale l'atto
di partecipare un'opera e sicuramente un
atto di introspezione che poi
soprattutto nella fascia generazionale
medio bassa ha una tendenza
culturale e arricchente notevole a mio
avviso proprio perché si cresce con una
consapevolezza e un bagaglio culturale
ed esperienziale sicuramente più maturo
diverso dalla norma e va a creare
sicuramente degli individui
migliori secondo me
come dicevo mi è capitato nella carriera
di lavorare spesso in case famiglia
carceri anche mi viene in mente la
L'esperienza di Ascoli Piceno per cui
avevo vinto tempo fa un
un concorso e c'era la regola ferrea di
non poter interagire in nessun modo con
i detenuti Perché la struttura
[Musica]
teneva al suo interno anche di 41 bis e
invece non ce l'abbiamo fatta io i miei
colleghi abbiamo in un qualche modo
nonché in maniera spontanea coinvolto
alcuni detenuti che erano lì nell'ambito
infatti abbiamo una testimonianza di un
ragazzo egiziano che ha fatto una
bellissima calligrafia nell'ambito e
anche vigilanti anche il project manager
non è riuscito a placare questa tendenza
perché ha visto con i propri occhi
una spontaneità gestuale e anche
relazionale soprattutto che alla fine
dei conti in questi progetti fa davvero
la differenza
concludendo mi viene in mente
una delle esperienze più forti che ho
avuto in vita finora ed è sicuramente
legata all'opera che ho alle mie spalle
perché è sicuramente è un'opera che
nasce esattamente a Cagliari parlo
dell'Opera tragitto ed è un'opera che
sorta
in una casa diciamo di accoglienza per
persone disagiate e indigenti ed è anche
la sede del centro antiviolenza per le
donne questo luogo attraverso
quest'opera ricorda tutte le persone che
sono di passaggio lì che la vita è un
tragitto è che la parola tragitto
sconfina tra le piante tra tra le foglie
è un punto di luce in mezzo al cielo che
Squarcia la vegetazione e ai suoi piedi
ha un'immensa
scala fatta di binari proprio perché è
un'allegoria alla vita la vita è un
continuo tragitto
successivamente
venendo al fotogramma dove c'è il
celebre ritratto di Gigi Riva che tutti
conosciamo in questo campetto che si
trova Quartucciu
è un'opera realizzata sempre in
collaborazione con Domus de luna si è
consumato un avvenimento molto toccante
io quando stavo portando a termine
quest'opera stavo con alcuni colleghi
verniciando completando le fasi
aggiuntive di decorazione delle pareti
circondariali che incorniciano questo
bellissimo campetto ho avuto un ruolo
diciamo di mediatori in un qualche modo
oltre che di pittore quindi
La ONLUS ha deciso di chiamare
direttamente dalla casa circondariale di
Uta delle delle persone in libertà
vigilata che erano molto conviviali in
un qualche modo erano gioviali Erano
partecipato i lavori socialmente utili
sin dalla prima ora tranne un soggetto
che era sicuramente
palesemente visivamente Borderline molto
restio soprattutto a tipi di impieghi e
di direttive che partivano dall'alto e
quindi non faceva nient'altro che in un
qualche modo opporsi cercando anche in
un qualche modo di disturbare la mia
persona il mio lavoro e soprattutto
anche quello che era il lavoro degli
altri che erano intenti e concentrati
nel lavoro socialmente utile a un certo
punto questa persona
prende diciamo un rullo
invece che impugnare degli strumenti
convenzionali come dei pennelli proprio
perché era una superficie molto ruvida
io mi rendo conto che persi La la
pazienza
scavalcai la recinzione che ci divideva
e gli dissi io non so come come dirtelo
tu sei qua ad aiutarmi per un qualche
modo stai aiutando anche a te stesso
ci fu una piccola scintilla di
comunicazione non verbale tra noi due
che è partita da due sguardi lui Mi
guardò e mi disse
Hai ragione
e io andai a
depositare appunto il rullo che era
sporco che non serviva per quell'impiego
e tornando mezz'ora dopo dopo aver
sbrigato altri impegni
lo vidi che di sua spontanea volontà
era lì a lavorare dopo aver impugnato un
comune pennello in silenzio
perfettamente diciamo
con un basso profilo con estremo
rispetto si mise come gli altri a
lavorare
Ritengo che questa fosse
stata una
delle esperienze più toccanti anche uno
dei momenti di massima comunicazione che
ho avuto con un individuo soprattutto
difficile perché comunque si parla di
contesti dove le persone hanno dei
traumi alle proprie spalle hanno un
vissuto sicuramente molto buio e quel
tipo di linguaggio senza scontro ho
notato e me lo porterò dentro per sempre
è servito a qualcosa perché poi io
continuando a militare in questi ambiti
lo continuo a vedere ed è sempre più
fuori da da una cella è sempre più alla
luce del giorno anche come umore quindi
un individuo che
sta assaporando la parola riscatto
sociale e non la confonde per un altro
tipo di riscatto soprattutto
e quando avvengono questi avvenimenti Io
credo che
al di là di essere tecnicamente
portato o aver sviluppato un tipo di
stile un percorso artistico poi c'è
dell'altro anche in quello che faccio lo
vedo non da me stesso lo vedo da queste
manifestazioni che spesso si manifestano
in maniera davvero non verbale un po'
come il destino un po' come altre cose e
sono cose sono avvenimenti che
parlano un po' da soli che ti capitano
Nella vita devi avere tu la sensibilità
per captarli e tenerti lì dentro
soprattutto farne fanne tesoro
Che dire È sicuramente
un'opera che al di là della sua
iconografia
poi come tutte le mie opere hanno
dentro
degli avvenimenti
custodiscono delle delle dinamiche e
custodiscono anche
relazioni Anche perché gran parte dello
sfondo blu che c'è dietro il ritratto di
Gigi Riva è stato realizzato da più di
cinque classi dello stesso Istituto
d'alemanno Curtis che era appunto il
preside che si batteva per lo sport e
per una società più più luminosa
successivamente poi c'è stato
un'inaugurazione gigantesca dove anche
molti soggetti delle case famiglia e
bambini non tanto Insomma fortunati o
madri in difficoltà hanno felicemente
inaugurato quest'opera
ed è stato come vedere una cornice
barocca
sfarzosa attorno a quest'opera è una
visione un po' informale di un'opera
d'arte però
Penso che quello che faccio sia anche
arte relazionale poi va oltre un
fotogramma che può piacere o meno come
tutte le opere d'arte Grazie